you want to talk about janet rankin
who's one of my favorite people so
jeannette rankin was the first
woman elected to congress she was
elected before uh women's suffrage was
massive constitutional amendment from
montana she
was elected in 1916.
she was one of a handful of people to
vote against
the u.s going into the great war which
was the right call at the time she was a
pacifist
republican as well coincidentally she
lost her seat
ran again in was it 1940 got the seat
again
uh and was the only person to vote
against
getting into world war ii it was not a
unanimous choice
jeanette rankin was the one person and
she said you could no more win a war
then you can win a hurricane
so she's one of these interesting free
and talk about bravery
you're the one vote after pearl harbor
to say
we're not doing this and i mean the
pressure she must have been under at the
time
is uh and of course many people are not
interested in hearing her perspective
she's crazy she's evil blah blah it's
also funny someone on
my twitter when i talked about her goes
maybe she had hitler's sympathies like
yeah
ms rankin was a big fan of hitler
that's what you figured it out guys do
you think there's an argument to be made
that united states should not have
gotten involved in world war
ii oh easy an easy argument the argument
there's a i talk about this in the new
right
so on internet circles there's something
called godwin's law
which means the longer an internet
conversation
goes on the probability someone gets
compared to hitler becomes one
in certain new right circles the longer
the conversation goes on
the more likelihood that the argument
would come we should have been in world
war ii also becomes one
and the argument is at the very least
stay back
let hitler stall and kill each other off
and then go in and knock off the weaker
one and you're going to be saving
destroying two nightmare systems and i
think that's an easy argument to make
now it's hard to pull off after pearl
harbor
but in terms of strategy i don't think
that's a that's a tough uh
sell what about after pearl harbor i
mean that's what i'm saying
after pearl harbor how are you going to
sell that to the people the argument is
blah blah the holocaust
the holocaust is there's no scenario
where that doesn't happen really
if you're unless you're going in way
earlier but even so hitler had said if
the jews launched another war
you know we're going to wipe them from
the face of the earth so the jews are
being held hostage by hitler as an
argument for this
another thing he did which was you know
diabolical
is in order to make it that people could
not accept jews as
refugees if they were going to leave
germany they had to be penniless
so now you have it's not like they're
coming over with money and they can take
care of themselves no no
they're going to be completely destitute
it makes it harder to accept them yeah
millions of destitute people who don't
speak the language it's it's it's a
tough sell
you